قاطعا مسافه تصل الى 1900 كم مره خلال هذه
الامارات والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والكويت ثم العراق
امجد الكلباني شاب عماني في الثالثه
والعشرين من العمره استعان بدراجته
الناريه في رحلته الصعبه والمثيره في ان
واحد معا لحضور بطوله كاس الخليج بكره
القدم في نسختها الخامسه والعشرين التي
تقام في البصره الرحله بدات من مسقط من
عمان الامارات بيت هناك وكملت اليوم
الثاني من الامارات الى السعوديه الكويت
على البصره مسافه 1900 كيلو تقريبا يوم
ونصف بالطريق
ودخلت على البصره الساعه 11:00 بالليل وما
شاء الله يعني ما مشيت 50 متر اهل البصره
يستقبلونه وكل واحد يتعال وتفضل وتعالى
بيننا وما مقصرين صراحه كرم مش طبيعي
بصراحه
يقول امجد ان الهدف من هذه الرحله ايصال
رساله دعم للتلاحم بين شعوب دول مجلس
التعاون مع اشقائهم في العراق
رساله حب ودعوه للخليجين انهم يقع البصره
دعما للعراق ودعم للبطوله وهي رساله
المحبه واحترام واهل البصره فاتحين بيوتهم
فاتحين قلوبهم الحكومه فاتحه الحدود
ويخدمون بعيونهم من قصر المعاني
لم تعد هذه مجرد بطوله كرويه لكنها تحولت
الى محفل رياضيا ثقافي اجتماعي يجمع شعوب
دول الخليج العربي
بترحيب كبير وخاصا من قبل اهالي البصره
الذين يعتبرونه واحدا من نجوم بطوله كاس
الخليج لكره القدم بنسختها الخامسه
والعشرين من البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه